faut quand même l'hydrogène on le trouve
pas dans la nature faut le fabriquer
donc c'est quand même une combinaison
faut d'abord fabriquer de l'hydrogène
alors soit vous le faites sur base de
gaz avec des SMS et de la capture de
carbone soit vous le faites le fameux
hydrogène vert sur base d'électricité
des carbonées aujourd'hui on produit pas
d'hydrogène sur base des carbone sur
base d'électricité on fait pas de
l'électrolyse de l'eau pourquoi parce
que c'est simplement beaucoup beaucoup
plus cher que de le faire sur base gaz
donc quand on parle de faire des
millions de tonnes d'hydrogène vert sur
base d'électrolyse on en a pas dans la
il y a sur toute la planète il y a un
gigawatt d'électrolyseur donc on annonce
tous les jours des gigawatts et des
gigawatts d'électrolyseurs on n'a pas
l'industrie pour le faire juste pour
donc pour moi ça c'est quand même un peu
plus futuriste autant les bio au
carburants on les a ils sont matures
c'est une question de matière première
d'investissement on est dans l'étape
suivante qui va être d'être capable de
faire
d'avoir accès à cette hydrogène le
deuxième commentaire je fais sur
l'hydrogène est vraiment qui est un
sujet pour moi très important
quand l'Europe se donne comme objectif à
horizon 2030 de faire 202 de consommer
20 millions de tonnes par an d'hydrogène
dont 10 millions de tonnes par an
produit en Europe
c'est 200 GW d'électricité qu'il faut
qu'il faut construire
le ratio c'est en gros 2 gigawa 2 à 3
gigots ça dépend c'est de l'éolien du
vent pour
un million de tonnes d'hydrogène
c'est en fait profondément l'hydrogène
c'est de l'électricité l'hydrogène vert
l'hydrogène vert elle peut être
nucléaire il peut être renouvelable
c'est il peut être des carbonée surtout
le débat n'est pas là c'est que y
compris pour nous Français il faut qu'on
construise beaucoup plus que 8 réacteurs
nucléaires si on veut faire de
l'hydrogène vert en France parce que
pour l'instant les réacteurs on a besoin
pour déjà assurer l'électricité
quotidienne enfin de de celle qui nous
dans un besoin donc l'hydrogène demande
des capacités supplémentaires
par rapport à tout ce qu'on a prévu dans
la transition énergétique c'est un sujet
majeur qui est occulté parce que on veut
déjà faire transiter notre système
électricité actuel alors nous en France
il est décarboné très largement mais en
Allemagne il est encore du charbon etc
mais en fait il faut non seulement
remplacer ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui mais
si on veut faire l'hydrogène il faut en
ajouter le électricité et c'est pas des
petits volumes c'est pas des petits
volumes c'est des gigantesques volumes
donc le sujet hydrogène est un sujet qui
n'est pas simple
qui qui mérite et qu'il va naturellement
qui se traduit par des coûts